-You guys, we're back here
with "Late Night."
We're chatting with Bowen Yang.
It's very exciting. I know it
must be also exhausting.
But when you're off from "SNL,"
you were going over to London
because you were working on
"Wicked."
-Yes! Oh, my gosh.
It's so cool.
-This is amazing. This is
a film version of "Wicked."
-Yes.
-You're not just going over
to do, like, a show over there.
-Which I would happily do.
Especially because the cast
on the West End of "Wicked"
just fully digs into
the British accent
and it's so funny.
They're like,
[ In British accent ]
"We're going to see
the Wizard of Oz."
[ Laughter ]
It's really funny.
But it's great.
No, we're doing the movie
and it's crazy.
-And this is a show that
meant something to you.
-Yes, okay.
So the second time I ever
came to New York,
the first time I went
into Manhattan,
it was 2005.
"Wicked" had just come out
a year and a half before.
I was obsessed with it.
I was besotted by the songs.
And then I came to New York
and then I begged my parents
to buy tickets.
It was the hottest ticket
in town.
We couldn't go.
And I was like, "Well,
can we at least drive up
to the Gershwin Theater
so I can press my face
up against the glass?"
[ Laughter ]
And so we went.
It was the most pathetic sight.
-'Cause it's not like, I mean,
from my knowledge of
Broadway theaters,
the glass, you don't
get to see the set or anything.
-You don't get to see the set,
but you get to see the lobby.
You get to sort of touch things
that touch the floor
that lead to the stage,
so you're kind of like,
you're sort of like
a couple degrees away.
And so we couldn't do that,
but what we did do was,
we came to this building for
the NBC studio tour.
We got to go over to
the "SNL" studio
and sit there, and I was like,
"This isn't as cool as
'Wicked.'"
[ Laughter ]
-It must be very nice --
Do you ever reflect back on
the fact that you're
now working on the two things
that you --
one, were on
an underwhelming tour of
and two, you couldn't get
tickets for?
-Yes, I mean, it's crazy.
It's a crazy full-circle.
It's also amazing that they're
both Universal Studios projects.
Watch Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] But...
-So much synergy!
-The synergy is red-hot
coming off you.
-I promise it's genuine.
Like, I love Peacock so much.
I really do.
"Poker Face"
starring Natasha Lyonne
is premiering on it.
-Really good.
-It's really good.
But no, it's crazy.
It is full circle, though.
-Obviously, this is a musical.
Is there choreography involved
with your role?
There's choreography involved.
So Jon M. Chu
is directing the film,
and he is still working
with choreographers
that he's been with
since "Step Up 2."
And I was really intimidated
going into this.
I was like, "I'm not a dancer.
I don't know really
how to move."
-I would say,
just from watching "SNL,"
I do feel like you are
very good at sketch comedy
choreography, right?
-It's just the arms.
They're never panning down.
-Oh, that's interesting.
I have been fooled
by your arm work then.
-Exactly.
That's all sketch comedy dancing
really is.
But I was really scared to do
this, and then I went in
and I thought I was doing okay,
and then these
lovely choreographers
are validating you
at every turn.
They're going, "That's amazing!
Oh, my goodness!"
And then Christopher Scott,
the choreographer,
looked me in the eyes and said,
"Bowen, you're a dancer."
And I was like,
"Wow, I felt that."
[ Laughter ]
The next week, we're all on set
and some of the other actors
who are also not trained,
professional dancers and I
are talking about
the choreography.
We're like, "Oh,
it's pretty complicated,
but I think I have
a good handle on it."
And then two of them were like,
"Yeah, and Christopher Scott
looked me in the eyes and
was like, 'You're a dancer.'"
I was like...
oh, so I'm not that special,
I guess?
But it's gonna be great.
It's gonna be so good.
-You're not selling this movie!
[ Laughter ]
"I just cannot stress to you
how much the choreographer
lies to us."
-Yes!
Lies, but also ultimately
gives you the boost you need.
-I think the boost
is more important.
In the early days of
learning choreography,
I think a boost is far better.
I would respond better to a
boost than the hard truth.
-Totally.
-Yeah.
-And watch me get cut out of
the movie from dancing.
-Well, the best is,
every shot of you dancing
is definitely gonna be
from here up.
-Yeah.
-A lot of arm work.
-And then people at home
will be like,
"That's amazing sketch dancing
in this movie."
-And then it's gonna
cut to, like,
definitely someone else's legs
moving real fast.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-You get to go to London.
I know it must be hard because
you're obviously working
when you're there.
Are you enjoying
the city at all?
-I am. I'm really
enjoying the city.
The only note I have for London
is that, um,
they don't understand what
the concept of iced coffee is.
-Is that true?
Even in this day and age?
-I kind of think so.
Anywhere in Europe, you go,
"Can I have an iced coffee?"
and they look at you like
you've asked for, like, a
lobster thermidor or something.
I'm like, "I just want
coffee on ice."
And they go, "So an Americano?"
I'm like, "No, just give me
an iced coffee, please."
And they also -- London is
trying to like,
veer in the other direction.
They should embrace tradition,
reject modernity,
go back to meat pies.
You can't find a good
meat pie in London.
-Are you looking?
-I'm looking for a meat pie.
And it's not even
a Sweeney Todd thing anymore.
There's no, like,
worst pies in London.
There's no pies in London.
-Where does this craving
for a meat pie come from?
Is it just an expectation
you had of London?
-It's that.
It's me being like,
a Commonwealth baby,
being born in Australia,
going to Canada.
Meat pies are a thing that,
like,
I've accepted is never
gonna happen in America.
Americans just don't care
for meat pies.
But people who have
the Queen's face on their money,
like, love it, you know?
-So bring back the meat pies!
-Bring back the meat pies.
-Alright, well that is --
So if there's anything to
take away from this,
it's watch Peacock,
bring back the meat pies.
-Yep.
Bring back the meat pies
and Lenny Hochstein
is dead in this town.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
You guys, that's Bowen Yang.
"SNL" this Saturday.
Stream live on Peacock!
With host Michael B. Jordan
and musical guest Lil Baby.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."